alors allez les pères de quoi ça parle
bon ben ça va bien sûr parlé du rôle des
pères du rôle domestique mais aussi
familial alors c'est un article
qui est
co écrit par marie quartier anaïs collet
est elle sert ni pierre gilbert marie
hélène le chien si lui mon char
monchatre et camille nous et il a été
publié en 2021 dans la revue travail
genre et sociétés voient qu'une revue
selon son nom qui est plutôt qu'à plutôt
pour objet d'étude justement les rôles
les rôles gendre et où les rôles
masculins et féminins sans doute et
surtout dans le monde du travail donc
alors je ne fais pas toujours une
critique des des auteurs une critique
externe par porc aux auteurs parce que
bon à partir du moment où ils sont sur
kairn ou dans le corps de l'article donc
lors de la critique interne on se rend
compte qu'il ya une démarche de sciences
sociales et qu'ils ont été publiés dans
cette revue à comité de lecture pour moi
c'est bon je sais pas le but ici de
faire chaque fois une délégation se
complètent je sais que certains parfois
me le demande mais savez c'est parfait
ici en tout cas
alors je mens j'ai pas ouvert la version
g j'ai modifié j'ai modifié que j'ai
surligner
je veux celle là parce que là c'est plus
facile pour moi
alors ça commence bien avec la
croissance historique du taux d'activité
des femmes le modèle de la famille
traditionnelle organisée autour de la
mère au foyer et du père pourvoyeur de
revenus dominant au milieu du siècle
dernier est désormais un fait
minoritaire donc il ya toujours cet
élément de contexte qui est proposé et
qui est assez intéressant pour moi c'est
déjà le début de la problématisation
parce qu'il ya eu une évolution et qui
dit évolution des choses intéressantes à
les analyser évidemment et à comprendre
l'entrée massive des femmes sur le
marché du travail n'a pas conduit à une
plus grande égalité dans les foyers donc
on aurait pu se dire au départ mais oui
il y avait des rôles homme femme qui
était très très différent où il y avait
interrogé it est importante à partir du
moment où
on allait les femmes qui deviennent plus
présente sur sur le marché du travail
dans la vie active on aurait pu se dire
bugs saleh a évolué de de soi même j'ai
envie de dire mais c'est pas le cas nous
voyez c'est ça la problématisation c'est
vraiment d'avoir des éléments qui
viennent un petit peu contredire notre
intuition ou la logique
alors bien sûr on parle de la charge
mentale et que aujourd'hui les femmes
vont devoir affronter en tout cas les
maires vont devoir affronter une charge
mentale beaucoup plus importante la
charge mentale
c'est le fait d'avoir plein de
préoccupations différentes de porter la
responsabilité de différentes choses et
de sa carrière puisque maintenant les
maires une bonne partie sont actives la
persistance de ces inégalités s'explique
à la fois par l'organisation du marché
du travail et par le maintien d'un
modèle patriarcal de la famille dans
lesquelles l'activité professionnelle
féminine reste une variable d'ajustement
voilà on nous apporte déjà un petit
élément de réponse
la division sexuelle du travail
domestique se noue pour une part
importante au moment de l'arrivée des
enfants et donc voilà c'est vraiment
dans la situation que
on a à ce moment là une différenciation
des rôles familiaux et domestiques c'est
quand les enfants arrivent sinon avant
on pourrait considérer que en tout cas
c'est ce qui sous-entend dû à mon sens
c'est que les rôles sont beaucoup plus
égalitaire et c'est l'arrivée des
enfants qui introduit de l'inégalité
dans les rôles ou une hétérogénéité
c'est selon
parce que je suis avec les fenêtres ici
bon tout ça pagnes évidemment
d'injonctions à être de bons parents ça
c'est aussi dans l'air du temps et dans
l'évolution est d'ailleurs bien une
collègue qui m'a vous et il n'y a pas
très longtemps la semaine dernière ben
en décours parental hors jeu pas c'est
comme ça que ça se formule en tout cas
de se faire aider pour bien faire les
choses ces injonctions incontestablement
pèse avant tout sur les femmes
évidemment
c'est pour ça qu'elles ont d'ailleurs
une une charge mentale c'est pour ça que
je dis évidemment
et ce qui est aussi intéressant mais je
vois que j'ai pas forcément souligné
ce passage là mais il est très important
peut-être que ça viendra par la suite
mais je vous le donne quand même c'est
que
cette norme cette nouvelle norme
parental qui est définie être de bons
parents est souvent aussi accepté par
les pairs et les pair impair ppe accent
grave et roeulx lez père
accepte le fait que maintenant le rôle
d'un père c'est aussi
plus d'égalité dans justement la
répartition des tâches familiales et des
tâches ménagères des tâches domestiques
donc ça ils l'acceptent ils ont cette
représentation là mais on verra que ça
ne produit pas des effets et c'est ça
qui est vraiment intéressant autour de
la problématique
la période boraine se caractérise ainsi
par des diversités de normes familiales
donc on va constater qu'il y a il ya
beaucoup de types ou de mode de
fonctionnement et parental mais aussi
par la variété des dispositions de genre
incorporé par les individus cette
diversité normative et 10 positionne l
indice positionnelle ça renvoie comme on
disait à la socialisation j'ai déjà des
mots qu'on a entendues dans des lectures
précédente introduit démarche de jeu
susceptible d'orienter l'engagement dans
les tâches domestiques et la division
sexuelle du travail celle ci varie en
outre comme le montrent plusieurs
enquêtes selon les contraintes
professionnelles et les appartenance de
classe donc là les auteurs et les autres
ils se basent sur des des enquêtes
précédentes notamment galthie en 2011
c'est bruce en 2015 pour dire qu'on a
déjà deux variables explicatives mais je
reviendrai un petit peu parce que là en
fait ils sont en train de nous proposer
leur modèle leurs modèles d'analysé avec
lord hypothèse en complément de ces
enquêtes statistiques cet article alors
ça c'est la spécificité de cet article
si cet article vise à éclairer les
conditions sociales de l'engagement des
pères dans le travail domestiques et
parentales donc on sait qu'il existe
déjà des variables mais on veut aller
plus loin en
explorant une nouvelle piste qu'il
viendrait compléter
et donc ça c'est très intéressant je
trouve comme article est en tout cas
c'est très clair j'aime les articles qui
sont très claires au niveau
méthodologique où il ya vraiment une
démarche expérimentale fins
expérimentales mais en tout cas une
démarche empirique qui va être fait pour
vérifier quelque chose alors ici ils ont
sans doute beaucoup travaillé par
induction donc c'est à dire que sans
doute qu'ils ont fait d'abord leurs
observations pour après produire le
modèle théorique qui nous propose ici
mais ça peut important on s'en fout
lana libre en complément de ce jeudi
pardon l'analyse s'appuie sur une
recherche conduite en 2015 2016 auprès
de trente couples hétérosexuels donc on
pourrait se poser la question d'ailleurs
j'avais un élève qui avait travaillé qui
avait pris comme objet d'étude les
couples hétérosexuels aussi et on avait
dans nos discussions quand il avait
construit son objet d'étude c'est à dire
maintien commence à jour et dans des
couples homosexuels et sans doute qu'il
existe des des études qui ont été faites
là dessus parce que dans un couple
homosexuel
du coup la division la division genres
et des tâches domestiques elle apparaît
moins évidente 1 donc ça serait très
intéressant et là ça serait aussi une
belle problématique à travailler parce
que voilà dans sa formulation
il ya des des pâtes pas forcément des
paradoxes mais des choses qui rentrent
en collision ou en confrontation
ainsi la division du travail et genre et
que se passe-t-il dans un couple
homosexuel ou on a des personnes de même
genre voilà même sens que je sais pas
comment il faudrait le dire pour ne
choquer personne mais voilà quoi ça sera
une problématique tu vois intéressante
mais ici ça l'est aussi c'est une autre
problématique et on verra pourquoi elle
est intéressante j'ai déjà dit mon vers
là dessus alors ce sont aussi des
couples parents de jeunes enfants on
verra tout à l'heure je vous diffuserait
un petit peu le panel les 7 30 couples
on a leurré on a le détailler ici ça
c'est original enfin d'habitude je pense
pas qu'on cite ça toujours il ya les
noms et les noms de famille les prénoms
des personnes
donc ça c'est la première fois que je
vois ça va peut-être que ça existe
souvent et que c'est simplement qu'ils
aient pas vues 1
et ils sont qu'aux habitants aussi ce
dispositif permet d'étudier la réception
des normes de parentalité évoqués
ci-dessus et la manière dont elles se
traduisent en pratique donc
l'acceptation des normes l'intégration
des normes la compréhension si ces
normes la conscience de ces normes j'ai
envie de dire mais aussi la mise en
pratique
il faut sortir mais je pense que si vous
êtes si vous êtes sur ce stream c'est
parce que vous êtes sensible à ça ray
fokam sortir d'une vision dans laquelle
c'est parce qu'il ya normes il ya
forcément comportement j'ai encore une
discussion avec mes collègues vendredi
puisque nous étions réunion sur le
règlement d'ordre intérieur où certains
collègues et prétendait que parce que
les gens ont signé un règlement ils vont
forcément appliqué les normes gym
arrêter quoi ça c'est le monde le monde
des bisounours qui n'a jamais enfreint
le code de la route pourtant tout le
monde sait qu'il ya des choses à ne pas
faire pourtant on les fait quand même
le travail non déclaré
c'est des choses qu'on ne peut pas faire
voilà qui sont interdites pourtant il ya
des gens qu'ils le font enfin voilà on a
recours à du travail du travail non
déclaré on le fait soi même donc voilà
il faut aussi les normes sociales
qu'elle soit légale ou pas les normes
elles sont transgressées assez souvent
ça dépend lesquels évidemment mais ici
c'est vraiment ça qui est intéressant il
ya intégration des normes ou en tout cas
conscientisation de ces normes et
comment ça se passe au niveau de la mise
en pratique de ces normes et on parle
bien de ces normes de parentalité de
nouvelles parentalité dans laquelle les
parents doivent être de bons parents et
où l'homme puisque c'est ici on
s'intéresse à opère où l'homme doit
être aussi quelqu'un d'attentif qui doit
aussi éduquer ses enfants qui doit aussi
participer à la vie domestique et ainsi
de suite
et d'accéder aux aspects restant le plus
souvent dans l'angle mort des antennes
des enquêtes statistiques comme la
charge mentale les négociations
conjugales l'évolution des arrangements
les sentiments et l'économie de la
gratitude entre conjoints est donc ça
c'est tout des choses
qui sont déjà moins souvent abordé mais
qui en plus est là ça fait écho à des
débats qu'on a eu notamment avec tva sur
l'importance des observations quand
qualitative pardon c'est bien de faire
du quantitatif mais c'est parfois un peu
sec comment les individus vivent t-il ça
tu pourrais constatée par un
questionnaire à grande échelle j'ai
pendant cinq six mille 6000 répondants
voient dix mille qui te disent voilà
simplement oui en effet c'est plutôt
madame qui qui va s'occuper du médecin
quand les enfants sont malades et
monsieur qui va juste peut-être
s'occuper des extérieurs qui travaillent
plus des choses comme ça mais après ça
ne te dit pas comment les gens vivent et
là tu as besoin d'une enquête
qualitative et j'ai envie de dire tu as
du quantitatif tu dois avoir du
qualitatif et puis quand tu as du
qualitatif tu reviens sur du quantitatif
parce qu'ici ils vont nous proposer des
choses qui sont valables pour les 30
personnes et toutes façons qui sont
valables pour les trente personnes ils
le disent eux-mêmes où elles le disent
elle même parce qu'elles sont plus
nombreuses
ici comme motrice du document
il ya quand même une diversité de
modalités familial et donc une enquête
quantitative permettrait un petit peu
d'objectivité ça un peu mieux tu vois
donc moi je trouve que en fait à une
quand une enquête qualitative une
enquête quantitative pourrez suivre et
en même temps après une qualitatif qui
hendrix enfin voila moi je pense que
c'est un dialogue permanent entre avec
la méthode quantitative et qualitative
bonsoir arnaud nanar tu vas bien
depuis la dernière fois
en l'airplay pendant les trajectoires
sociales qui leur donne sens et donc
c'est souvent sac permet de
de le qualitatif c'est de donner du sens
et surtout le sens que donnent les
acteurs ou les agents à leurs actions ou
leurs agissements
en comparant des couples contrastée
quant à leur appartenance sociale et
territoriale l' enquête vise à
identifier les contexte favorable à une
division plus égalitaire du travail
domestiques et parentales et à restituer
les logiques donc elle veut expliquer
expliquer dans cet article la variable
dépendante donc celle qui veut être
expliquée c'est tout simplement la
division du travail comme égalitaire ou
inégalitaire donc la variable elles
varient soit elles varient entre du
travail domestique et familial plus
égalitaire ou du travail domestique et
familial moins égalitaire c'est là que
vraiment la variable expliqué
il s'agit aussi de prendre en compte les
écarts sociaux entre conjoints est de
plus en plus fréquents en comparant les
couples homos gamme et les couples
hétéros gamme alors il ya 30 40 ans
d'ici la grande majorité des coupes
étaient homos gamme ça veut dire que tu
es tu as tué avec un compagnon qui a des
caractéristiques socio économiques
équivalentes aux tiennent donc on
parlera bien sûr du diplôme ou de la
profession plutôt de la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle donc par exemple on
pourrait constater que très peu
d'agriculteurs sont mariés avec une
cadre où son couple avec une cadre
supérieure
voilà c'est par exemple un grand écart
qu'on trouvera très peu et donc c'est ce
qu'on nous dit ici en tout cas on se
base sur bernard giraud qui en 2018
disait que les écarts se réduisent et
donc on a plus en plus de couples
hétéros gamme où on aura des origines ou
des conditions assez différente
alors les engagé dans le domestique
seront confrontés au monde des femmes
c'est un peu long de parler de ça à toi
le bouzin ok je prends ma charge y'a pas
de soucis mais je vois pas trop ce que
tu veux dire seront confrontés au monde
des femmes
qu'est ce que tu entends par là c'est
pas très clair pour moi
ça l'est peut-être pour toi mais moi je
ne vois pas bien où tu veux en venir
alors vite je vais quand même parlé d
éléments méthodologiques parce que
peut-être que ça vous intéresse moins
mais
la chaîne est là pour ça c'est aussi
pour parler de comment on fait des
sciences sociales en tout cas c'est mon
objectif premier donc je vais je vais
lire juste l'encadré qui ne parlent que
de métrologie l' enquête conduite dans
le cadre des postes enquête à lenquête
statistiques de la drees sur les modes
d'accueil des enfants des jeunes enfants
de 2013 s'est déroulée dans les communes
rurales et urbaines d'île de france de
rhône alpes du limousin des pays de la
loire et d'alsace auprès de parents d'au
moins un enfant de moins de 5 ans
formant des couples hétérosexuels
cohabitant c'est ça qui est bien dans
les enquêtes de sciences sociales tout
est
transparent
tu peux tout retracer c'est ce que je
dis souvent aux élèves comme si vous
faites un travail de sciences sociales
on doit pouvoir refaire ce que vous
allez faire
retrouver les éléments
bonsoir ami tu comment tu vas
je suis content de te voir
kotz différents jargon
je suppose que répondez à arnaud
d'honneur
il ya du vip 1 il ya du vide dans le
chatt 1
voilà tant que j'ai des badges pour les
habitués je mets un petit bip alors là
je crois que les cas il y aura bientôt
un petit bip qui va sortir mais ça fait
plaisir de voir les vip 1
nous avons rencontré trente couples
homos gamme et hétéros gamme se
distribuant de la manière suivante 6 de
classe supérieure 4 de classe moyenne 11
2 places populaires stable comme
précaire on avait bien vu la différence
il ya trois semaines entre les stables
et précaires 5e' pogam alors voilà ses
hippo gami pergame moi c'était des
concepts ou des qualificatifs que je
connaissais pas donkey paugam c'est les
femmes à la position sociale supérieure
à celle des hommes est hyper gamme c'est
la situation inverse donc ça moi je ne
savais pas du tout ce ce langage là
alors remplace le rôle celui dont elles
sont éduqués pour ce qu'elle n'accepte
pas facilement et je les comprends bien
sûr ah oui mais un certain moment quand
on parle je crois qu'il ya des
malentendus ou je dis pas que c'est le
cas dans le cast mais quand on parle de
rapports de domination comme le rapport
patriarcale
je pense qu'on prend pas en
considération toute la violence
symbolique qui est présente et que les
dominés jeudi les dominer parce que là
en l'occurrence ce sont les femmes qui
sont dans la position défavorable
accepte cette position et revendique
cette position dans certains cas et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait que la
domination est difficile à déconstruire
on est en plein dans le concept de
violence symbolique et donc c'est c'est
tout à fait vrai
avec ça alors je dis tout de suite
attention on est sur des thèmes qui
parfois sont polémique
moi ici je ne fais que des sciences
sociales comme je dis aux élèves ça
c'est les choses telles qu'elles sont
après ce que vous voulez dans la vie ça
c'est de la politique
si vous voulez changer les rapports
hommes femmes c'est votre droit si vous
ne voulez pas les changer c'est votre
droit donc moi c'est pas parce que je
vis un article de ici qui va
déconstruire certaines choses que je
prends position d'un côté ou d'un autre
et d'ailleurs je vois que amy tu réagis
sur la domination masculine c'est assez
c'est assez cocasse une fois
comme je sais qu'il y beaucoup de
français dans le chat et quand je dis
une fois j'ai vraiment l'impression de
ferme au belge une fois tu voulais
il ya quelques années une collègue
avait vu que je lisais la domination
masculine et elle me dit mais en fait tu
tues tu es favorable parce que tu lis la
domination masculine que favre à la
domination masculine elle que ne sais
pas le contenu 1 ii du bouquin
mais mais voilà mais non je suis
favorable à rien du tout alors après si
vous voulez mon avis évidemment je suis
pour plus d'égalité mais voilà c'est pas
mon but ici de faire de la polémique je
pense que c'est assez clair mais voilà
quoi
je tiens à le préciser
parce que après
j'ai déjà eu un sur youtube des
commentaires oui voilà vous voulez tout
déconstruire et tout ça sans moi je suis
pas
déconstruire pour le plaisir de
déconstruire je suis juste là juste là
je
objectif c'est juste comprendre le monde
dans lequel je vis et le monde il est
comme ça alors je le comprends comme il
est quoi après tu te saisi des objets
comme tu le souhaites ça c'est de la
politique
et après tout les temps je respecte
toutes les opinions à partir du moment
où elles sont respectueuses des autres
aussi
oui mais tu as je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi à l'honneur
mais après les revenus bon projet mais
quand même je vais quand même la
défendre cette collègue qui avait dit
que j'étais en faveur d'une domination
des hommes parce que je disais un livre
qui s'appelait la domination masculine
après elle s'est renseignée et elle est
revenue quelques mois après en me disant
non je retire ce que j'ai dit je
m'excuse elle avait bien compris le sens
du truc mais bon domination masculine de
pierre bourdieu ça fait longtemps que je
me suis plongé dedans mais c'est quand
même un bouquin qui est pas facile
facile
après globalement c'est pas non plus les
thèmes
j'aime bien j'aime bien lire ces objets
là ça m'intéresse beaucoup de comprendre
mais c'est pas les thèmes
voilà vers lesquels je vais le plus
facilement parce que peut-être que je
vois là je suis un homme un homme blanc
d'un certain âge et que c'est pas les
thèmes qui m'intéressent moi je préfère
vraiment les thèmes vraiment très très
sociologique
les classes sociales voilà c'est
vraiment le truc comme on a lu il ya
deux trois semaines avec l'écologie et
les classes populaires ça c'est vraiment
ça c'est vraiment le truc que je kiffe
non mais moi j'avais bien compris arnaud
nanar mais au début voilà c'était pas
très clair ton premier truc mais après
quand tu as dit le voilà on remplace
leur rôle et tout ça
moi j'avais bien compris mais toi sont
voilà après s'il ya des gens qui
considèrent que
la société remettront en question ça va
trop vite que sèche je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on pourrait
trouver bon voilà après opinion ça se
défend peut en discuter
mais voilà après je vais vous dire
franchement
j'ai appelé ma femme
quand j'étais en train de lire l'article
je dis ah tiens qu'est ce que tu penses
de ça et ces choses là nous on a un
couple voilà qui est très réflexif par
rapport à tout ça évidemment
on est vraiment dans une égalité on
essaie d'avoir une égalité
je vais pas dire parfaite dont nous dans
nos relations dans la vie domestique
mais on se rend compte qu'on reproduit
des schémas traditionnels
ma femme s'occupe de tout ce qui est
largement je m'occupe de tout ce qui est
extérieur bon après y'a des trucs que je
fais dans la maison
ll va pas forcément au jardin donc voila
mais on reproduit quand même des schémas
c'est elle qui porte une grosse partie
de la charge mentale donc après tu peux
même être très conscient des mécanismes
et les reproduire toi même parce qu'un
certain moment voilà ça vient un peu par
réflexe tu le fais comme ça et puis
après tu te regardes et tu te dis bah
ouais là on a reproduit des rôles
voilà quoi mais on n'est pas non plus à
vouloir déconstruire tous les rôles
domestique con
je trouve ça n'a pas plus de sens de
vouloir les maintenir que de vouloir
tout déconstruire par principe
alors je ne sais pas si comprends bien
tu as
ton message don quichotte mais on lui
dans une saucisse de toute façon
impossible d'y échapper si ça veut dire
tous on voit là on est dans la matrice
est et on est socialisé comme ça il n'y
a pas de judas correct ouarkoye
on évite souvent les mécanismes les plus
d'encre est peut-être parce qu'on a la
flemme ou la peur de découvrir tout ce
qu'il reste à faire oui parce que c'est
sans doute pas facile de d'innover de
créer des nouvelles normes sociales tout
simplement d explorer et la ménagère
elle veut le progrès mais pas la
pagaille
une belle heure
de gaulle aussi était contre la
déconstruction du coup ah oui mais moi
je suis pas contre un on est bien
d'accord non je précise je sais que vous
le savez probablement mais comme ça
après y aller les replays je veux que ça
soit très très clair je suis ni pour ni
contre les choses je constate les choses
et voilà et déconstruire ces comprendre
les choses mais c'est pas le plaisir de
déconstruire pour déconstruire
puisque de toute façon il y aura
toujours des rôles jean rey mais si vous
voulez c'est un petit peu j'écoutais
encore hier soir et ce matin des élèves
comment dire
main tarissables
l'ineffable frédéric lordon est un ce
moment il assiste à un petit une petite
discussion dans un cercle marxiste et
anarchiste est incertain il ya une
personne qui lui pose une question oui
mais bon
les institutions est ce qu'un jour les
institutions n'arrivera à bout des
institutions et lui dit non parce qu'en
fait toute organisation politique
nécessite une institution alors ça va
pas être une institution comme l'armée
l'église l'école
voilà mais il dit même
même au chiapas mamo
dans les régions où il ya des systèmes
plus
libertaire il ya toujours un système
institutionnel qui arrive quoi et la
personne était très déçu et alors
vraiment différent mais voilà moi
j'étais au contre les institutions mais
voilà c'est un petit peu ce à quoi que
tu le veuilles il y aura toujours des
institutions parce que ça fait partie
voilà d'une vie en société et des rôles
il y en aura toujours alors déconstruire
tous les rôles à ce moment tu arriveras
à quoi parce qu'il y aura toujours des
rôles qui se recrée centraliseront d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors peut-être
qu'ils seront moins stéréotypé mais il y
aura toujours des rôles domestiques des
rôles familiaux qui existeront c'est bon
c'est mon avis comme il est extra il
existera toujours des normes alors voilà
j'enseigne à des élèves voilà qui sont
dans dans leur adolescence on recherche
de beaucoup de choses qui se pose
beaucoup de questions et alors vraiment
disent oui mais bon chacun fait comme il
veut les nomme les normes vestimentaires
monsieur chacun fait comme il veut vu
mais je lui dis mais quand tu dis chacun
fait comme il veut tu es occupé à
réinstaurer une mauvaise nouvelle norme
alors peut-être une norme qui est
peut-être préférable à d'autres je ne
sais pas c'est pas je mens je porte ici
mais c'est toujours une norme comme quoi
on n'en sort jamais de cette histoire
j'ai du code et construire mon éducation
par conviction et aussi parce que tout
le monde était très différent vingt ans
plus tôt oui mais toute façon ça c'est
sûr qu'on a été tous contraints et
forcés et c'est d'ailleurs de quoi de ça
que par l'article puisque l'article nous
dit qu'il ya eu depuis une trentaine
d'années la l'arrivée de nouveaux de
nouvelles normes parentale et donc c'est
vraiment énorme parental qui fait aussi
qu'on se voit qu'on change beaucoup de
choses m'ont aidé en une et dans une
époque alors moi je dis toujours aux
élèves je pense qu'on est dans une
épaule a dans une époque anomique
ça n'engage que moi c'est vraiment
qu'une opinion mais voilà il ya vraiment
une perte de sens de beaucoup de normes
sociales qui étaient présentes on a déjà
beaucoup parlé il ya vraiment un
décalage entre ce que vivent les gens et
les normes telles qu'elles se sont
encore
affirmé par des agents de socialisation
et bon voila si on en suit les
enseignements de durkheim ici pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas mais vous
connaissez sans doute les situations
anomique c'est quand même de cette
situation qui sont compliqués au niveau
de la société parce qu'il ya des choses
voilà qui
qui se passe dans une situation
endémique mais je pense vraiment qu'on
ans d'utilisation anomique depuis depuis
un certain temps oui 20 ans sans doute
le début à 20 ans alors là je me base
que sur un ressenti personnel et
d'ailleurs il y avait sur les réseaux
sociaux un article qui tournait pendant
le confinement qui était
doit-on désobéir et tout le monde dans
les commentaires oui les temps de
désobéir ou de faire ceci mais moi je
n'ai j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a jamais
autant désobéi en fait hein donc la
question n'est plus
faut-il désobéir mais dans quelle
proportion
désobéit ton je pense d'ailleurs les
réactions sécuritaires qui ont pu naître
en france surtout plus qu'en belgique
sans doute ne sont que la contrepartie
de sahin pour moi ya toujours des
équilibres comme ça qui se forment mais
voilà bon après voilà ça c'est de
l'analyse à plus ou moins deux balles
personnel
mais c'est une long débat les normes et
les normes gendre et les normes
domestique et donc premier al
les objets étaient en train de lire la
méthodologie
donc 5e' paugam 4 hyper gamme les
couples de classes moyennes et
supérieures du privé sont plus nombreux
dans notre corpus que ceux du public où
les pères participent le plus au travail
domestique les entretiens menés avec les
deux conjoints séparément donc ça c'est
vraiment la mythologie
donc en gros ils ont fait 30 entretiens
explorer les arrangements autour de la
guerre des enfants la division du
travail parentales et domestiques et sa
perception par les conjoints leurs
expériences de socialisation à cet âge
ainsi que leurs trajectoires
professionnelles résidentiel et
familiale parce qu'on a vu aussi à
l'endroit où tu vis à beaucoup
d'incidence sur des comportements sains
jeudi l'endroit où tu vis ça peut être
le logement même mais aussi
l'endroit géographique
l'enquète ne portait pas ça peut
paraître évident mais si tu es parisiens
ou par rapport à une un village de la
campagne c'est totalement différent
aussi et encore ça dépend de quelle
campagne l'anc et ne portait pas sur les
couples séparés et certains couples ont
refusé nos sollicitations les inégalités
et les tensions ils sont peut-être plus
les plus fortes mais là c'est vraiment
une hypothèse qui restera sans
vérification
les parents donc là je suis plus dans la
méthodologie je continue la lecture de
l'article les pères rencontrés ont tous
intériorisé la norme du nouveau père
présent auprès de ses enfants donc c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que tous
les pères savent qu'aujourd'hui tu peux
plus être un père comme il ya trente ans
où tu n'en touche pas une fois où tu
regardes tu n'aimes pas tu es enfant tu
ne prends jamais dans tes bras donc là
il ya une intériorisation de serre nomme
cette norme s'ils s'investissent dans ce
qu'on peut appeler un travail de
sécurisation des enfants il participe au
travail domestiques et parentales avant
tout en tant qu'auxiliaire de leur
conjointe un donc c'est j'aide ma femme
mais pas voilà je fais les tâches
ménagères et on se répartit les tâches
ménagères non c'est c'est toujours
j'aide ma femme est d'ailleurs c'est des
choses que je dis aussi parfois mon
épouse j'ai fait ça j'ai pris l'avancé
pour toi ou des choses comme ça et puis
au moment où ça sort on se dit waouh je
me suis encore fait avoir par par tout
ce que j'ai incorporé et intérioriser
alors probable man un peu plus que 20
ans à vue de nez c'est venu de façon
très progressive à partir de la deuxième
guerre mondiale oui mais personnellement
voilà j'étais pas l'art ce moment là
donc je n'ai que que 40 ans de recul
quoi et même pas
20 ans pour moi c'était il ya quarante
les normes sociétales change vite et
tant mieux vu le progrès presque partout
je suis d'accord il me semble que par
conséquent ma génération connaît des
crises d'absurde de l'essence pour une
jeunesse qui veut son printemps par le
feu
alors c'est
j'ai envie de dire c'est ça me plaît
beaucoup sur la forme parce qu'il ya des
des formules que tu utilises qui sont
des groupes nominaux qui sont percutants
mais je ne comprends pas forcément tout
le fond
il me semble par conséquent ma
génération connaît des crises d'absurde
de l'essence
pour une jeunesse qui veut son printemps
par le feu
ça c'est demain je ne vais jamais d j'ai
fait le taf au détriment de mon travail
mais totalement assumé on le verra après
on le verra après
plus loin on va en parler des
différentes trajectoires
cet article vise à rendre compte des
logiques bouger cnis sylvain ouais donc
logiques qui explique la faible hausse
entre parenthèses faible de la
participation des pères ou travail
domestiques et parentales ainsi que la
persistance des inégalités donc je
résume une dernière fois la
problématique parce que c'est ce qui me
semble particulièrement intéressant dans
l'article c'est qu'il ya une intégration
du rôle
du nouveau rôle de père
mais en fait ça ne se traduit pas en
pratique par une participation des pères
au travail domestiques et parentales ou
en tout cas par une faible et pas une
participation parfaitement égalitaire ou
qui tendrait vers une grande égalité
voilà
ouais on est là
tu trouves panda rouge on est dans une
époque anomique
de perte de sens généralisée
ça c'est un truc qu'on pourrait
rechercher comme objet c'est l'anomie
est-ce que mais je crois que c'est un
concept qui est plus trop utilisé jeudi
peut-être une bêtise mais je pense que
tu es tellement c'est un concept qui
était trop large trop flou et qui est
plus utilisé mais ferait peut-être une
recherche sur l'anneau me ce pourrait
être un article intéressant la jeunesse
à supposer que ça existe oui déjà est
désormais minoritaire en occident mine
de rien c'est inédit et ça contribue à
cette anomie
peut-être c'est un élément à prendre je
suis d'accord aussi que la jeunesse ça
veut rien dire
je passe mon temps à le dire à la
jeunesse
non je le dis souvent aux élèves
premier titre inégalités
professionnelles rapports de classe et
engagement masculin des forces et d'être
un bon père
éviter à tout prix d'être une mauvaise
mère voyez déjà une nana symétrie les
injonctions faites aux parents montrent
une forte asymétrie liés à la
persistance d'une représentation du
travail féminin comme subordonné aux
exigences de la maternité
correctement dans ma collègue qui
suivent un qui se fait aider par rapport
à son rôle de mère s'il son compagnon
participent aussi à ces ateliers je lui
demanderais
mais tous sont restés employés à temps
plein tandis que presque toutes les
mères de deux enfants et plus sont
passés à temps partiel ou ont pris un
congé parental donc là je fais des
sceaux dans l'article pour pas tout lire
mais voilà déjà première différence on
voit que c'est asymétrique parce que
c'est surtout les mères qui vont réduire
leur temps de travail les rares
l'enquêté n'ayant pas fait ce choix sont
plus diplômés que leur conjoint donc on
est dans les couples y paugam est
engagée dans les trajectoires
d'insertion professionnelle donc il faut
prendre ça aussi en compte les
différents éléments match ensemble les
enquêtés qui ont quitté leur travail
pour s'occuper de leurs enfants se
rencontrent en bah comme en haut de la
hiérarchie sociale mais c'est plutôt les
choeurs de position qui va pouvoir
diminuer l'inégalité en fait
si la femme a une position sociale une
provision professionnels plus valorisés
ou plus hiérarchiquement plus haute à ce
moment là
l'inégalité devient moins effective
moins efficiente
la précarité les horaires le salaire
ainsi que la reconnaissance statutaire
des emplois structurellement
défavorables aux femmes s'avèrent ainsi
décisif dans les arbitrages des couples
à la suite de l'arrivée des enfants
toutefois deux facteurs exerce de
puissants effets de rééquilibrage c'est
bien dire équilibrage le travail en
horaires décalés et les alliances hétéro
gamme dont on vient déjà de parler plus
au premier facteur qui contribue à
rééquilibrer le partage des tâches les
horaires de travail décalés qui
conduisent les deux parents à se trouver
à tour de rôle seule à la maison avec ou
sans les enfants
que ce soit pour quelques heures ou pour
des journées entières donc tu veux de
l'égalité dont les tâches domestiques et
familiales
tu mets les pères tout seul à la maison
ils vont être obligés de le faire ça que
ça veut dire alors en ce moment j'ai ri
à certains passages en me disant mais
les hommes sont quand même terrible quoi
parce qu on est tous sur des données sur
un échantillon sur un panel où ils
reconnaissent tous qu'il faut plus
d'égalité parce qu'ils acceptent les
normes parental donc à ce moment ils
reconnaissent qu'il faut s'occuper des
enfants et en a que vous allez voir il
ya deux couples je pense qu'ils veulent
vraiment une asymétrie mais il le
souhaite mais tous les autres veulent
des dahus plus d'égalité mais quand tu
vois leur comportement mais c'est m
c'est en fait il faudrait en faire une
comédie quoi
peut-être que ça existe un alors vous
allez me dire c'est pas risible bien
serein je me retrouvais aussi dans les
situations et ça me faisait rire
nerveusement quelque part en temps mais
je le fais aussi ça
alors du coup
cette situation dans lequel les
les pères se retrouve seul à la maison
ça va être surtout valable pour les
classes populaires et les classes
moyennes puisque qui travailla pause qui
travaillent en service coupé qui
commence à 6 heures du matin ou plutôt
ben voilà c'est plutôt des métiers qui
vont être pratiquées par les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
alors vous savez que j'aime aussi quand
les gens racontent un peu leur vie est
ici on a quelques passages où on a
vraiment dû témoignages plus ou moins
brute et donc on l'a on nous avons
raphaël olivet 1 comme je vous le disais
les noms sont cités ça c'est rare âgé de
34 ans ouvrier non qualifié dans
l'industrie automobile dit pouvoir
profiter entre guillemets de son fils de
deux ans et demi dont ils ceux qui
s'occupent à titre principal cinq demi
journées par semaine jusqu'au
licenciement de sa conjointe là ça a
changé ouais le fait que la conjointe
reviennent au domicile suite au
licenciement
ça a changé un petit peu la situation on
ne développe pas ça s'il souhaite éviter
le recours à un mode de guerre de payant
pour des raisons principalement
financières
il participe très largement aux tâches
domestiques et son implication auprès de
son fils découle aussi de
l'incorporation de la nouvelle norme du
bon père s'occupait entre guillemets de
l'enfant mais aussi le connaître entre
guillemets donc passé vraiment les mots
qu'il donne et en profiter entre
guillemets tout comme l'enfant doit en
retour pouvoir profiter de ses deux
parents les olives et sont également
réceptifs à la puériculture psy
aussi entre guillemets parce que c'est
un concept qui a été en tout cas donné
ou en tout cas une appellation donnée
par gaujard en 2000 ils ont rencontré
notamment à la maternité leur fils est
né prématuré et y rester six semaines
qui a forgé en eu l'idée que le père
doit lui aussi partagé des moments de
complicité avec son fils que ce soit par
dédain ou des massages donc là on voit
aussi l'agent de socialisation
secondaire qui arrivent dans leur vie
pour inculquer entre guillemets cette
culture cette culture psy
cette culture cette nouvelle culture
l'adhésion aux nouvelles normes de
parental de paternité pardon vient ainsi
donné sens à ces configurations de
travail qui ne sont généralement pas
choisi son retour celles ci permettent
l'endossement de ce rôle de nouveaux
pères et voyez ça c'est tragique mais
j'ai envie de le dire vraiment avec
beaucoup de coeur parce que c'est
vraiment waouh quoi il ya plein de films
très très sociaux des oeuvres très
social voilà que j'aime beaucoup lire
mon épouse me dis mais comment tu peux
lire ça c'est vraiment déprimant mais
parce que oui c'est déprimant parce
qu'il ya un tragique du social qui est
quand même incroyable les gens en fait
on toujours les idées de leurs
conditions vous savez je voulais déjà
dit tout le le comment dire l'attrait
que j'ai pour l'oeuvre l'oeuvre de marx
mais voilà mais je suis profondément
matérialiste
comment dire de manière historique je
pense
voilà mais je pense qu'on se met le
doigt dans l'oeil quand on pense que les
gens décident de leur vie c'est toujours
les conditions qui vont déterminer nos
modes de pensée et vous voyez comme ici
cette culture qu'ils reçoivent à la
maternité vient recouvrir leurs
conditions et il s'en saisissent non pas
parce qu'ils sont convaincus mais parce
que ça fait écho à leur condition et ça
peut venir redonner du sens redonner de
lyon1 sortir de cette situation anomique
de cette condition anomique dans
laquelle il était peut-être par des
services coupés par du travail
comment dire à pause qui faisait perdre
du sens dans leur vie quoi du coup le
temps qui est dégagé par leurs horaires
contraignants mais à leur permettent de
s'occuper chacun à tour de rôle de leurs
enfants et ils viennent tous liés avec
cette culture cette paire culture psy
qu'ils ont reçue à la maternité
alors j'avoue on est foutus
c'est un peu de ça que je parlais au
début la tech être à tout prix une bonne
mère peut impliquer une forme de refus
de partager cette tâche refus ou
négation web c'est juste je comprends
mais j'ai du mal à y croire entièrement
je pense que la majorité des femmes
accueillerait volontiers le fait que
leurs mecs passent le taf aussi
oui une question de proportion alors ici
on va plutôt voir que ces pandas rouge
dans l'article c'est plutôt panda rouge
qui a raison
mais on est sur un échantillon
relativement réduit moi je viens d'un
milieu populaire donc je connais
beaucoup de gens de milieux populaires
mais voilà c'est la femme ne veut pas
que l'homme touche au moindre balle et
ou autre chose comme ça quoi mais je
pourrais vous donner des noms
c'est ça serait faire injure
situe si tu ranges la table à leur place
et c'est quasi un affront que tu fais
que tu vois et j'en connais donc bon
après dans quelles proportions ça je
vous laisse je vous laisse débattre là
dessus mais
voilà il ya il y à il ya des deux types
alors s'y habituer sa maman tu dis tu
les scientifiques en ce sens ça me fait
plaisir parce que oui moi je veux pas je
veux pas être
influencée par mes opinions par mes
billets tous alors je le suis je sais
que je le suis mais c'est pour ça que la
condition d'être humain parfois
m'insupporte c'est parce qu'on ne sait
pas sortir de ces billets mais c'est sûr
que voilà quoi
j'en ai déjà parlé sur ce chat dans ce
chat
mais il ya une valeur qui pour moi est
super importante c'est la lucidité
d'être lucide sur les choses voilà moi
je veux pas être dans la matrice je veux
être à l'extérieur de la matrice je vais
être dans le vaisseau avec morpheus
alors si vous connaissez pas le film
matrix c'est bien dommage parce que je
fais souvent référence à ce film
d'ailleurs les élèves ont gentiment ils
font un polo pour les profs chaque année
et alors on peut mettre son nom ici et
je leur dit non mais vous ne mettez pas
monsieur deramaix vous mettez ce que
vous voulez je vous laisse seul seul
c'est vous qui mettait le pseudo que
j'aurai sur mon pull et donc il ya deux
ans avant le coup vite le
l'avant-dernier pull m'ont fait vraiment
plaisir parce qu'ils avaient mis spinoza
orcanta spinoza sur ton pull bon voila
tu ne dois pas le mettre n'importe où
parce que si les gens pensent que c'est
toi qui tu appelles spinoza mais cette
année si l'on était un peu plus subtil
mais ça m'a fait tout aussi plaisir ils
m'ont mis morpheus voilà mais voilà moi
je veux je vais être du côté de morpheus
1 je veux pas être comme cypher vouloir
retourner dans la matrice est donc pour
moi
être lucide sur le monde sur les choses
c'est avoir un esprit scientifique du
coup
majoritairement les femmes on les
cherche domestique il ya pas photo moi
je parle du nouvel engagement des hommes
dans ce domaine voilà
oui je vous laisse débattre après moi je
prendrais pas partie ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre je pense que vous avez tous
les deux raison de toute façon il ya des
femmes qui demande et on va le voir dans
cet article si par contre il y a des
des femmes qui sont dans sans doute dans
un dans un process de violence
symbolique qui ont complètement
intériorisé la norme et qui n'ont pas
envie quand on fait une identité et qui
n'ont pas envie en tout cas à l'heure
actuelle de sang sont dégagées à manger
pas non plus le donneur de leçons et
c'est pas du tout mon trip d'aller dire
aux gens oui mais tu domines et machin
voilà les gens font ce qu'ils veulent
voilà moi je trouve que l'internement
prendre la position du monsieur je sais
tout c'est vraiment la pire qu'on puisse
prendre
alors on passe à un autre paragraphe un
autre titre d'ailleurs homogamie hétéro
gamme il est fait des positions sociales
relatives les alliances hétéro gamme
plus courantes que par le passé se font
généralement à proximité dans l'espace
social c'est à dire que tu vas pas comme
je le disais tout à l'heure les
alliances
agriculteurs cadre supérieur reste très
rare et ça va être plutôt des alliances
cadres supérieurs employés par exemple
qui sont plus proches dans l'espace
social
mais plusieurs couples de notre corpus
présentent des écarts sociaux prononcer
statistiquement improbable encore une
fois c'est pas parce que l'essentiel des
poissons nagent qui a pas de poisson
volant mais c'est pas l'essentiel de
l'espèce d'ailleurs ils ne veulent pas
vraiment comme on me l'a fait remarquer
une fois sur le chat dans les couples
rencontrer la division sexuée du travail
n'est pas affectée par le niveau de
diplôme qui aujourd'hui place
majoritairement les hommes en position
inférieure dans les coupes c'est aussi
c'est quelque chose qui change étant
donné que les femmes ou une meilleure
scolarité vont beaucoup plus loin dans
la scolarité il ya un renversement qui
est qui est en cours
je sais pas si on peut parler d'un
bouleversement démographique pas ce
qu'est ce que le niveau de diplôme
niveau d'éducation est une variable
démographique
en tout cas il ya un bouleversement là
qui est en cours avec un retournement
alors encore faut-il qu'ils soient
qualitatif parce que le problème c'est
que les femmes vont vous le savez sans
doute plutôt dans des filières moins
valorisés que celles dans lesquelles
vont les hommes mais je pense que ça va
très vite évoluer
quoique quand tu regardes sont encore en
école d'ingénieur alors c'est dommage
que yann et quelques ingénieurs sur le
chat
alors
d'âge parce que là
arnaud nanar
me provoque on va faire un petit sondage
rapide
pour voir un peu d'interaction en plus
on est courant de 8 c'est sympa comme
nombreux 8
je vais vous poser la question est ce
que vous préférez
comment il s'appelle le vaisseau dans
matrix
alors petit sondage prof
alors je rappelle
que le 19 juin on se voit
pour la sociologie est un sport de
combat si vous n'étiez pas encore là ce
moment-là
nouveau sondage référez-vous
steak saignant
et c'est la pilule bleue je pense pour
rester dans la matrice
est ce que
est ce qu'il ya des maudits pilule le
là je vous fais un truc aux petits
oignons 1 faudra participer un steak
saignant ou alors bouillasse
bouillasse de riches s'est passé c'est à
dury et là c'est la pilule rouge
quand je vais pas aller à vous dire
jusqu'à comme je dis aux élèves celui
qui prend la pilule bleue il peut
changer d'option
mais c'est un peu tout comme
et l'or
permis le multi vote comme ça phoenix
peu bourré d'azur
c'est parti
le début 4 nazaire c'est sa
façon le mot est trop long pour le
mettre dans le sondage le nez buccale
désert bon bah voilà est ce que vous
préférez le steak saignant dans le
restaurant de la matrice de la matrice
avec cypher ou est-ce que vous préférez
une bonne bouille as de riz sur le nez
du câble nezzar
avec morpheus alors je sais plus le nom
de tous les âges de trinity évidemment
et tous les autres
os
comme ils sont en train de troller le
sondage
je continue en regardant la fin du
sondage tout à l'heure les résultats du
sondage
[Musique]
le rapport de classes renforçant le
rapport de jean les couples hyper gamme
dans lesquels je rappelle un conflit
perriam c'est un couple dans lequel la
femme à une
situation professionnelle supérieure à
celle de l'homme dans lequel les hommes
ont une profession même chose mais en
fait je vais expliquer alors que c'est
expliqué à l'ats par la phrase suivante
à la phrase suivante dans lequel les
hommes ont une profession et des
ressources économiques supérieures à
celles de leurs conjointes
figurent ainsi parmi les plus
inégalitaires et en plus j'ai dit
l'inversement a contrario l'ipo gami
position et ressource professionnelle
des femmes supérieure à celle de leurs
conjoints atténue ce rapport de pouvoir
comme le montre d'autres travaux sans
toutefois l'inversé donc là on a des
variables qui sont explicatif simplement
la position relative des dans le couple
la position professionnelle relative
dans le couple va être un facteur
d'inégalité ou d'égalité
dont la participation aux tâches
ménagères et familiale
l'ipo gamine n'est pas une condition
suffisante toutefois pour modifier le
rapport de pouvoir
autre témoignage ici c'est ce que montre
le cas du couple formé par pierre
pochard agents de contrôle sûreté dans
un aéroport d'origine populaire et les
ja zerkaoui cadres dans les
télécommunications originaire d'une
famille située entre les classes
populaires et la petite bourgeoisie
indépendante c'est le couple ou les
tâches sont les plus partagés alors
petite digression mais qui va peut-être
être une grosse digressions la semaine
dernière je disais tiens le nombre de
fois où bourdieu et quand même cité dans
les articles c'est quand même
impressionnant est ce qu'il ya des
billets est ce qui est ce que c'est moi
qui choisis de des objets qui sont
propices à une analyse bourdieusienne et
ainsi de suite on en avait discuté là
dessus mais ici tu vois que bourdieu
n'est pas dans la biographie mais on
renvoie quand même mais en ce moment il
y aura capitale culturelle aussi qui
sera évoquée puis là c'est très
bourdieusien en fait encore une fois
donc bourdieu est quand même un peu
partout même si c'est pas que lui qui a
utilisé ce terme ait là quoi
c'est le couple ou les tâches sont les
plus partagés alors que leila y
travaillent à temps plein honoraires
classique de bureaux endosse le rôle et
les préoccupations de braid winner un de
soutien de famille pierre qui
travaillent principalement de nuit
assure une part importante du travail
domestique on retrouve cette contrainte
horaire qui fait que l'homme va
s'occuper plus des tâches ménagères et
familiale y compris des tâches
habituellement féminine lessive
repassage cuisine repas courses jardin
jeux avec les enfants gestion
administrative du foyer sans que cela se
traduise par le retrait de leïla qui
assurent une part conséquente du travail
et de la charge mentale gestion de la
garde-robe des choix de vêtements
rangement de la maison suivi médical
jeux avec les enfants histoire du soir
les horaires décalés permettent à ce
père de s'investir dans le rôle de bon
père entre guillemets évidemment bon et
de compenser son statut social peut
valoriser tout en exerçant un
contre-pouvoir éducatif face à l'
influence de la lignée de dominion de sa
conjointe trop centrée selon lui sur des
valeurs matérialistes évidemment elle
est du côté du capital économique
voilà on revient encore du texte les
pères au travail parental décomposer le
travail parental permet de mieux
comprendre la force limité de cette
norme il peut en effet être déclinée en
quatre composantes qui a un pôle le fond
empiéter sur le travail domestique et à
l'autre son autonomie des tâches de
production domestique à sa première
chose à provisionner cuisine est rongé
nettoyer ça c'est la détache production
domestique et à laitages de prestations
aux enfants faire manger
vais soigner un billet qui mobilise très
inégalement les pairs mais aussi des
pratiques de socialisation par les
loisirs l'exercice de l'autorité
l'accompagnement d'apprentissage et de
transmission qui contribuent à la pente
de la trajectoire sociale du lignage et
dans lesquels tous les pères sont plus
investis nogré père va être plus
investis sur la transmission la
socialisation que sur les tâches de
production et de prestations aux enfants
des couples fortement spécialisés et des
couples substituables donc en fait on a
une sorte de typologie qui se dégage
dans le premier cas les tâches de
production dans les couples fortement
spécialisés et de prestations aux
enfants sont entièrement assumé par les
maires avec un coup de main ponctuel des
pères qui peut consister à occuper les
enfants pendant qu'elle prenne la charge
le ménage ou la cuisine
en charge par dont le ménage ou la
cuisine dans les couples plus
substituables les pères assument des
prestations quotidiennes aux enfants en
partageant le mot revient souvent avec
leur conjoint dans une forme
d'égalitarisme lié à une conception de
la famille comme une unité de production
à laquelle chacun doit contribuer
solidairement ces couples de classes
populaires se caractérise non seulement
par les horaires décalés ou atypiques
qui conduisent les pères à être seul au
foyer on l'a vu mais aussi par une
socialisation des hommes au travail
domestique dans leur enfance et au cours
de leur trajectoire il manifeste un goût
pour le travail des choses bricolage
jardinage mais aussi cuisine et
nettoyage mais oui mais c'est tout à
fait logique si tu es d'une classe
populaire dans une classe populaire on
n'a pas l'occasion de
de faire appel à du personnel
d'engager quelqu'un pour ranger la
maison pour s'occuper du jardin ou
aujourd'hui par exemple avoir un robot
qui tond sa pelouse ou des choses comme
ça et donc c'est tout le monde doit
mettre la main à la pâte les enfants
doivent prendre en charge aussi des
tâches ménagères plus en tout cas
et donc voilà il dégage encore une fois
leur leurs conditions leur vécu font qu
il dégage un habitus qui va leur faire
apprécier
et
intégrée vraiment cette norme de goût
pour le travail des choses le travail
concret en y associant d'ailleurs
souvent les enfants
certain nombre de tâches demeure presque
exclusivement dévolue au maire gestion
du linge lessive repassage rangement
gestion du stock et choix des tenues des
enfants jouent directement ça c'est
totalement le cachet wako du travail
domestique santé ça aussi c'est le cas
chez moi c'est à ce moment là j'ai
appelé mon épouse mais un petit peu voir
et si ce qu'on raconte
suivi des prises en charge médicale des
vaccinations soit un quotidien gestion
de la pharmacie
quoique la gestion de la pharmacie ça
c'est plutôt moins 20 c'est un peu les
deux et lorsque les mères sont plus
diplômés que leur conjoint du travail
administratif attends tu t'es tu
t'étonnes de la charge mentale
ou c'est madame qui paye la facture
aussi
la gestion des comptes et du suivi du
travail scolaire en plus
autre cas chez les brosses chauve et
yannick s'occupe des devoirs de son aîné
mais c'est karine qui se rend aux
réunions organisées par l'école et
qu'ils signent cahier de liaison la pub
donc là c'est vraiment leur témoignage
la plupart du temps je lis et puis après
je le donne à karine parce que quand il
s'agit de signer ou d'écrire un petit
mot c'est karine qui fait et ça c'est un
exemple que je donne souvent aux élèves
alors les élèves me dise monsieur
aujourd'hui au niveau domestique les
hommes il faut beaucoup plus aidé et je
leur donne toujours l'exemple du de la
gestion de la scolarité des enfants
et personnellement en réunion de parents
c'est
généralement en réunion des mamans quoi
c'est plus souvent la réunion des mamans
que des papas quant à des papas c'est
soit avec la maman alors là c'est pas
des preuves je donne c'est vraiment
juste dû témoigner un jeu donc ça ne
vaut que tu que que don
dans cette visée la cua donc c'est soit
des des parents qui viennent à dieu ou
alors si ce n'est pas pas à bien c'est
souvent quand le couple est séparé
mais des papas qui viennent tout seuls
c'est très très rare s'ils sont voilà
s'ils sont encore en couple avec la
maman quoi je dis c'est que dans le car
c'est vrai moi moi c'est mon vécu ah non
j'ai pas trente six mille élèves non
plus
mais ça ça reste vraiment un truc qui
reste très très inégalitaire
alors ici il ya des
des femmes qui ont totalement
intériorisé l'inégalité parce qu'ici
elle dit il m'aide beaucoup j'ai de la
chance
alors c'est pas le même couple c'est un
autre couple mais ils mettent beaucoup
j'ai de la chance il est quand même un
cd chose que les femmes disent ah il me
il me met le dernier en pyjama quoi
voilà c'est déjà ça il fait déjà
beaucoup de choses devraient donc là il
ya une intériorisation aussi
d'inégalités
finalement qui est pas remise en
question dans ces énoncés couple l'a 1
pour reprendre un petit peu le débat qui
avait entre arnaud et
[Musique]
et panda rouge
je reviens quelques instants sur le
tchat
olalala mais ça c'est lamentable tout le
monde 20 94 pour ce nous commandent 94 %
des votes c'est le steak saignant mais
il faut savoir que phoenix a contribué
avec 63 points de shell donc phoenix à
troller le sondage mais bon voilà on ne
l'avait pas interdit c'est ça la matrice
parfois ya des surprises
bon je pense que sans le trollage de
phoenix ilya 4 sur 6 4 qui prennent la
pilule rouge seulement sur eux sur sept
sur sept votants
bon bah
vous faites du mal alors sur ce stream
bon du coup j'ai perdu ma fenêtre
[Musique]
répartition des votes ok je peux faire
mes retours
voilà je 7
qu'est ce qu'on raconte ici
bonsoir mahmoud haut ça fait déjà un
petit temps qu arriver ça fait dix
minutes que tu arrivé je ne t'ai pas
saluer mais je n'ai plus été de sur le
chat depuis dix minutes
bienvenue
alors on se pose la question ici est ce
que le sondage va confirmer le cours de
l'histoire où l' inverse le conformisme
sera-t-il la règle et la révolte
l'exception
nous n'irons pas jusque là messieurs pas
encore la révolte
c'est une application qui permet d'
interférer sur les votes non en fait je
peux quand tu crées un sondage sur
twitch tu peut autoriser plusieurs votes
avec les poings de chaîne
vous connaissez les points de chaîne
c'est en bas du chat si tu restes
longtemps basse accumulent des points de
chaînes se permet d'après de jouer et
d'aider moggi des choses comme ça mais
ça permet aussi de voter plusieurs fois
et sur un stream précédent il y avait
déjà phénix qui avait bourré les urnes
ça m'avait bien amusé et donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai permis
plusieurs votes et donc la phoenix sont
est donné à coeur joie de manière assez
subtil je dois dire parce qu'il a juste
mis ce qu'il fallait pour faire
pour
comment dire pour que ce soit vraiment
très très
très stalinien comscore
on va r
ah oui
faites comme chez vous pas de souci j'ai
lu bourdieu mais il faut en vouloir je
ne conseille pas si vous lisez peut
trouver non mais tout à fait quoi
alors des bons vulgarisateur de bourdieu
il y a sociaux le geek qui a fait une
vidéo sympa que j'avais bien aimé
celle là était sympa je peux la vous
mettre vous la mettre dans le
chat le lien vers cette vidéo là
après j'en ai fait toute une série
mais qui n'ont pas forcément la même le
même ambition que
que celle de sociologie ou lui voulait
réaliser une vidéo assez exhaustif et
moi j'essaie vraiment de lire bourdieu
chapitre par chapitre en tout cas la
distinction donc sur la société ecc qui
aura un certain nombre de vidéos où
j'essaie d'être assez proche de ce que
dit bourdieu a précédé vidéos qui sont
très imparfaite ou je suis pas un as du
montage et donc voilà
alors je gère la pharmacie de ma copine
histoire de libérer mon garage
chacun son vécu paphos en général c'est
moi qui me tape les réunion
parents-profs et on m'a demandé si on
était séparés a battu voix voilà parce
que tu es sans doute l'exception ou une
des exceptions
l'implication des pères est considéré
comme précieuse celle des mères
surabondante et même relou ça va être
dit ça ça va ça va être dit dans
l'article par implication comprendre
amour oui mais à ce moment les pères
vont reprocher ça justement tu as tout à
fait raison dans l'article il en parle
beaucoup plus loin
je les fais aussi j'avais 15 ou 20 ans
que les autres parents qui étaient
toutes des femmes voilà
comme disait papy cioran
la lucidité rend libre dans un désert
donc je comprends les bouffeurs de steak
même si ce n'est pas mon choix a room
mais moi j'ai pas dis je les comprenais
pas
la lucidité rend libre dans un dessert
c'est beau mais c'est beau aussi auront
d'ailleurs en philosophie c'est ce que
j'ai dit aux élèves parce que là il y en
a quelques-uns qui ont un trip si orange
qui sont occupés à lire si haut rang et
au début m'avait dit à monsieur si haut
rang qui souvent pensé j'y vais à moi
c'est un des derniers
suivront ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
philosophe mais en tout cas c'est un des
derniers voilà j'ai lu parce qu'une fois
que j'ai lu tio ranger plus envie de
lire autre chose je me suis dit voilà on
est arrivé au bout du bout il a il a
tout dit voilà parce que c'est voilà
c'est en même temps très juste très
tragique
c'est beau merci en tout cas pour
partager ce à quoi la lucidité rend
libre dans un désert mais c'est
exactement ça c'est d'une vérité je
trouve mes
excès et s'est dit si simplement désolé
de metz beau dire devant une une
aphorismes mais j'adore ça quoi quand
ils sont ciselés
et c'est exactement chat le ça que tu
sois tu décides des plus idée en fait tu
vas être très seul très isolé
très déçue très
comment pourrais dire
ou soit tu acceptes voilà j'ai pas dis à
l'hypocrisie parce qu'il s'agit pas de
ça mais tu acceptes les écrans tu
acceptes les mensonges qu'on que l'on se
fait à soi même d'abord un spa les
mensonges qu'on fait aux autres mais
d'abord les mensonges qu'on ce moment à
soi même est alors la vie sera plus
confortable mais c'est exactement la
métaphore de matrix merci en tout cas
pour cette citation
du père ouais mais je préfère celle de
si haut rang
un truc comme ça alors vous étonnez pas
parfois y'a des trucs dont je sais pas
mais faire un concours de citation sur
twitter est ce que c'est ça serait sympa
de se faire un concours de citation sur
twitch vous venez avec vos plus belles
citations et on ceux des balances comme
ça quoi ça serait cool une fois non
dans un milieu hostile qui décide d'être
heureux
-
[Musique]
là quand c'est du stand-up pour porter
de lunettes
ouais let's go
on cesse baudillon s'esbaudit mans
n'avance pas d'un iota
alors
du côté des pratiques de socialisation
les loisirs des enfants activités
partagées dans la plupart des couples
rencontré relève du registre des tâches
discontinue gratifiante et optionnel
auquel les pères participent le plus
systématiquement mais c'est la même
chose aussi avec les tâches ménagères
qu'elle est une des tâches ménagères que
les hommes vont faire le plus c'est la
cuisine parce qu'en fait c'est celle qui
est et surtout la cuisine quand il ya
des invités un camp c'est un petit peu
un repas de gala où un repas de prestige
le repas voilà avec des convives là
l'homme va mettre la main à la pâte
parce que il ya c'est plus valorisé
c'est plus gratifiant quelque part ça
c'est les hommes
je vais pas d'essentialisme
le week end quand on n'a pas la tête au
travail là il s'occupe des enfants ce
que je veux dire c'est une citation d'un
d'un témoin classiquement alors que les
maires se consacre plus volontiers à des
activités d'intérieur dessin pâte à
modeler jeux de société jeux préparant à
la maîtrise des couleurs des formes des
lettres oui c'est tout de suite aussi
très scolaire
les pères rencontre et quel que soit
leur propriété sociale investissent les
jeux d'extérieur le vélo les parties de
football ou de basket accompagnent leurs
enfants pour les activités sportives ou
culturelles parfois assistent aux
entraînements et aux compétitions
vous voyez même sur les activités qui
vont être faites quand il y a
participation de l'homme et de la femme
aux activités de l'enfant
quelle qu'elle soit il ya une
différenciation aussi genre et quoi ça
c'est intéressant ce qui peut se
prolonger à l'intérieur autour de jeux
vidéo ou de match regardé ensemble dans
les classes populaires ou moyennes
certains pères intègrent leurs enfants à
leurs propres loisirs et occupations
domestiques comme ça voilà ça la retarde
pas dans tout ce qu'ils ont à faire ou
ce qu'il pense devoir faire plusieurs
paires donnent à leurs enfants de
petites missions dans la préparation des
repas l'entretien du potager ou du
jardin comme antoine dufour agents de
sécurité qui laisse les nuages huit ans
conduire les véhicules qu'ils utilisent
pour tondre leur grand terrain est
rapportée du bois de chauffage
je passe quelques lignes il mène en
effet un travail propre de socialisation
et de transmission peu étudiée par les
sciences sociales oui ça serait vraiment
intéressant
pour les pères ouvriers et techniciens
donc généralement quand un auteur qui
dit que c'est peu étudiés c'est que ça
n'a pas été étudié pour les pères
ouvriers et techniciens qui inclut leurs
enfants dans leurs loisirs ou leurs
activités domestiques leur la
transmission de leur goût pour le
travail des choses dont je parlais et
pour les activités extérieures n'est pas
dénuée d'un rapport stratégique à
l'avenir comme chez raphaël olive et qui
décrit la dimension pédagogique de ces
pratiques partagées et là il témoigne
parce que moi lire une histoire c'est
pas mon truc
chanter une chanson c'est pas mon truc
c'était pas mon truc si par exemple je
vais bricoler ou tondre la pelouse des
trucs comme ça bah c'est plus c'est un
plus quoi il pourra peut-être mieux
avancer après chez un patron pour faire
son apprentissage un enfant il apprendre
plus de choses avec l'alternance un coup
à l'école un coup dans l'entreprise moi
j'en ai fait l'expérience après ça
dégourdi mieux l'enfant enfin la de
l'essence
tous les perdre
privée jai privilégie pardon dans les
loisirs la mise en mouvement des corps
les ford le grand air la prise de risque
voir la compétition surtout s'ils ont
des fils alors c'est marrant parce que
j'ai un copain sur facebook qu'ils
partagent tous le temps ces parties de
pêche avec son fils et son fils étaient
vraiment très très petit quand ils ont
commencé à la pêche et donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est une belle
illustration de ce qui est dit dans le
texte
les pères cadre insistent plus sur la
wii et il a une fille aussi mais alors
parfois la fille et sur les photos mais
on voit que c'est vraiment avec le fils
qui veut montrer les gros poissons c'est
d'abord des photos avec son fils et puis
avec la fille il fait une photo avec le
poisson mais
il y en a qu'une quoi par exemple tu
vois donc on retrouve vraiment ça
les pères cadre insistent plus sur
l'autonomie des enfants et sur la
nécessité de les éloigner de leur mère
protectrice on revient ce que tu disais
1,7 et panda rouge qui disait ça hein
donc les mère protectrice entre
guillemets les père ouvrier employé m e
plus l'accent sur la prouesse physique
et la débrouillardise
les hommes en fait ils vont être
vraiment sur la sécurisation des enfants
et sur les perspectives à long terme les
pères se montre particulièrement
préoccupé par les transmission différée
de capital économique notamment la
sécurisation de la trajectoire des
enfants reposent de même sur la
transmission du capital culturel et du
statut social qui se traduit par une
mobilisation autour des enjeux de
réussite scolaire particulièrement
remarquée dans les classes moyennes et
supérieures mais même sur ce plan on
observe un engagement plus important des
maires dans l'accompagnement scolaire
proprement dit tandis que les pères
veille davantage à la sécurité physique
et sociale des enfants d'un truc belote
si la division sexuée du travail
domestiques et parentales
reste largement inégalitaire elle n'est
seulement cependant pas déterminé une
fois pour toutes par le degré des
terreaux gamme i ou ii mogami des
couples ni par leurs contraintes
horaires professionnels donc ça ne
suffit pas pour rendre compte de toutes
les réalités qui sont observés danser en
couple
résulte des multiples ajustements
relationnel entre conjoints construit au
fil du temps de manière plus ou moins
conflictuelle et réflexive et j'ai envie
de dire que là on change de paradigme
alors le paradigme on dit souvent que
c'est les lunettes du sociologue c'est
la manière dont il voit l'objet d'études
là on était très dans un paradigme voilà
très bourdieusien petit peu
structuraliste comme ça et là on va
aller vraiment sur quelque chose qui est
plus dans l'interaction
alors tout d'abord on va justement
s'intéresser un aspect d'eads et âge des
mères qui est justement de mobiliser le
père dans les tâches familiales
domestique et donc ici 10 ans roulait
les pères un travail féminin ligne du
caractère avant tout féminin de ce
travail les pères montre une faible
réflexivité quant à leur contribution
réelle au travail domestique alors que
les maires sont toutes conscientes du
caractère inégal de cette répartition
dans leur couple en tout cas voilà pour
les chantiers on sait ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure
peut-être qu'à d'autres personnes qui ne
rentre pas dans ce canevas la
voit jamais oublier que les conclusions
de sciences sociales elles sont
relatives à ce que tu a observé tu peut
pas généraliser ou en tout cas très très
peu
alors que les maires sont toutes
conscientes du caractère inégal de cette
répartition de leur couple nombreux sont
les pères qui découvre au fil de
l'entretien
ils en font moins que leurs conjointes
et on a ce père qu'il dit c'est eddy
favreau et où le remerciera pour sa
franchise mais je suis un assisté en
fait note avec autodérision et 10
favreau en plat et logistique dans la
grande distribution
ici on a une autre témoin qui dit il ne
connaissait pas l'aspirateur je lui ai
présenté
leurs corps lâche parfois face à un
surcroît inattendue de travail donc on
l'a on parle des femmes et qui parfois
sont au bout du bout du rouleau prise en
charge de parents âgés donc il ya un
élément supplémentaire elle gère le
quotidien
mais il arrive un élément qui vient
perturber la belle mécanique enfin la
belle mécanique la mécanique en place
prise en charge de parents âgés décès
d'un parent qui devrait garder qui
devait garder ses petits enfants
naissances de jumeaux difficultés
scolaires ou problèmes de santé des
enfants forte pression travail et cetera
rompant les routines installé cet
effondrement déclenche alors des crises
conjugales qui conduisent à discuter
ouverture ment ouvertement de
l'investissement des pères donc est
aussi une sorte d'historicité de la
relation dans le couple qui fait qu' on
peut avoir dans certains couples et
c'est pour ça que tu peux pas te passer
du qualitatif tu vas voir dans certains
couples une répartition plus égalitaire
mais qui a été construite au fil du
temps et ça il faut comprendre aussi
donc c'est pas juste un déterminisme de
certaines variables
c'est aussi une construction de par les
interactions des acteurs j'aime
particulièrement ce à quoi enfin le
cette approche vraiment de venir
complexifier cette idée
on n'a pas dit qu'aujourd'hui ce serait
le concours de d'aphorismes don qui
choque
mais tu le dis la clairvoyance et le
seul vice qui rendent libres libres dans
un désert ça c'est là la bonne citation
à la citation complète
mais comme tu l'avais cité je trouvais
que c'était plus cinglant donc
c'était bien fait c'était bien citer de
mémoire parce que c'était vraiment
moi j'adore camus parce que camus un
style très très court voilà il ya c'est
simple c'est simple et profond en même
temps tu vois ya pas de fioritures et ça
j'aime aussi quand c'est très concis et
comme tu l'avais dit c'était vraiment
très très concis très beau par sa
simplicité
c'est un différent peut-être si tu as
des filles ou des garçons les sportives
féminines sont entourés de meuf à ce que
j'ai vu
j'interdis à mes mômes de dépasser ma
taille en grandissant ils n'ont pas obéi
c'est bien la preuve que le patriarcat
est foutu mais ahoua 1
les hommes accompagnent plus souvent
leur fils que leur fille pour faire
court oui sans doute peut-être
ils n'ont jamais cherché
à ben tu vas voir après ça va être ça va
être terrible l'aspirateur est un
instrument de torture pour me permettre
un ben oui ok
il n'a pas des silencieux maintenant
mais en fait ce qui est personnellement
ma femme utilise souvent l'inspirateur
et moi j'utilise plus souvent le ballet
où est la balayette
donc en fait moi j'utilise pas trop
l'aspirateur sauf pour nettoyer la
chaudière ce qu'on a une chaudière à
pellets donc il faut la passer
l'aspirateur c'est le seul moment où
j'utilise un aspirateur mais pas celui
ménagers
alors après voilà ce débordement de vie
privée
ça je les lui
mais pour bien d'autres couples les
tentatives féminine d'enrôlement du père
se heurte à des stratégies de résistance
dont la première est la passivité et
c'est là que je disais tout à l'heure un
panda rouge tu vas voir on va pas être
déçu parce que là tu vois les hommes
mais tu vois le 10 mai des claques des
claques mais à moi aussi un des claques
parce que je me rends compte que je fais
ça aussi un
il y en a un qui dit la conjointe
d'arthur kinect formateur dans un
organisme de formation professionnelle
pour adultes l'encouragent à se lever la
nuit les premiers mois de l' après la
naissance de leur fille ou de façon
insistante à gérer le linge c'est la
guerre dit il mais sans succès c'est la
guerre ça c'est le mot qu'il emploie
alors évidemment c'est sans doute avec
un peu d'humour mais c'est quand même un
peu la guerre quand même
les résistances peuvent aussi prendre la
forme d'un engagement minimal et
temporaires tu vois le gars il le faible
lefa moitié quoi de façon à donner des
gages sans entreprendre de
transformation de soi je vais relire
parce que quand j'ai lu ça j'ai dit
c'est dingue les résistances peuvent
aussi prendre la forme d'un engagement
minimal et temporaire de façon à donner
des gages sans entreprendre de
transformation de soi quoi mais tu vois
les hommes et comme ils sont quoi c'est
pas possible
désolé de mettre un peu de jugement de
valeur mais c'est quand même dingue tu
vois parce que encore une fois c'est des
mecs qui ont intégré la norme du nouveau
père
mais ils en sont quand même là
quand félicité samba qui est au chômage
qui assure l'essentiel du travail
domestiques et parentales sollicite son
conjoint agents de sécurité pour la
soulager afin qu'ils donnent leur passé
deux fils en bas âge il s'y attelle avec
si peu d'entrain qu'elle finit par s'en
charger elle-même quand je lui dis à tes
ma femme m'a dit mais tu fais ça elle
m'a dit tu le fais ça voyez on est
terrible quoi c'est terrible ah tiens tu
t'occupes des enfants vite fait je vais
aller me laver j'ai pas eu le temps il
va commencer cinq minutes puis je viens
j'en peux plus voilà il est pas patient
quand c'est lui il ya du riz partout
dans l'assiette je dis mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mais non il n'a pas faim
il a pas envie je dis bon merci je
m'assois et puis je dis regarde ils ont
tous mangé faut être patient c'est tout
quand ils veulent pas tu joues un peu
avec eux et puis quand ils oublient
turmel à une cuillère il accepte un donc
elle passe son temps pour les enfants
mangent bien le père il essaye cinq
minutes et puis il abandonne 2
comment expliquer ces résistances en
contradiction avec la norme égalitaire
c'est ce que je disais c'est ça qui est
dingue partagé par la plupart des pères
et leur relative efficacité
un d'un côté tu as la norme qui est
intégré et puis elles sont totalement
inefficaces
une partie de la réponse tient dans la
socialisation différenciée des conjoints
conjointe face aux situations concrètes
de prise en charge du travail
domestiques et parentales les
dispositions à agir et à se sentir
responsable s'avère très différenciée
selon le sexe bon pour nous en dire une
pareille on leur bien deviné tout seul
quoi entendre les pleurs de leur bébé la
nuit etc
il incorpore un sens pratique des femmes
qui met leur corps en mouvement quand
les hommes se montrent attentistes
et une belle différence de ressenti sur
les congés parentaux alors que les
femmes vont prendre des congés par an
tous pour s'occuper essentiellement de
leurs enfants parce que ça les hommes à
l'instar des pères en congé parental qui
conçoivent davantage cette période comme
un temps pour soi
tu vois il ya un profond égoïsme quand
même
ainsi c'est dans les couples où les
pères sont les plus impliqués que les
tensions sont les plus faibles et la
reconnaissance mutuelle la plus
fréquente cette réciprocité s'appuie sur
une perception commune de l'organisation
pratique comme ajusté à l'idéal
d'égalité partagé par les conjoints
quelle que soit sa forme a donc tout ce
qu'on vient de dire évidemment il ya des
couples dans lesquels ses traits et
galettes égalitaire comme on l'avait dit
en début d'article il ya une diversité
de situations
vision du monde privilégiant légalité au
sens d'un différenciation entre les
sexes ou représentation de la famille
comme exigeant un effort solidaire est
répartie de manière juste quelques cas
font cependant exception dans lesquelles
une organisation traditionnelle ou la
mère réalise presque l'intégralité du
travail domestiques et parentales
est associée à une forte gratitude
soutenu par une représentation
religieuse légitimant la spécialisation
sexuée déroulent
les quarts aile couple bourgeois de la
banlieue ouest parisienne très insérées
dans les sociabilités catholique locale
affirme on se demande pour qui ils ont
voté à faire ainsi se satisfaire de la
stricte vite division du travail
qui assigne à agnès la gestion du foyer
celle ci exprime de la gratitude à
l'endroit d'aymeric vous ne refait pas
le prénom non plus qui accepte de
l'aider
lorsqu'elle est trop fatigué et qui en
s'investissant avec succès dans sa
carrière et son emploi oserait extensif
pardon mais j'aime à gorki garde qui
grattent beaucoup
créé bénéficier la famille d'un statut
social élevé et des ressources qui y
sont associés la même situation
s'observe chez les poulets couple de
classe supérieure légèrement hypo gamme
ou qui s'opposent explicitement aux
effets d'un différenciation de la norme
de l'égalité le sexe qu'il juge
contraire à l'ordre naturel carrément
assignant opère la fonction d'autorité
et à la mère celle de la tendresse
moi je fais partie aussi de la timba les
bons soirs profs les nains
comment ça va bien
c'est dur effacer des siècles de
conditionnement social
ouais c'est sûr
et à tel point voilà c'est intériorisé
quelque part
entre les lignes on comprend la violence
que les hommes s'autorise pour compenser
leur absence de partage des tâches
là je comprends pas ce que tu veux dire
par là en fait on imite les sociétés de
saint jo je te laisse seul maître seul
juge de tes propos je connaissais pas le
mot est programmé j'ai été voir une
vision c'est à ces secteurs alors je
sais pas s'ils allaient vision que tu as
été voir mais peut-être que tu peux
mettre dans le chatt prof le nain la
définition du programme je vais pas
rappeler parce qu'en fait au début du
stream on a beaucoup parlé mais une fois
là la définition que retrouver si tu
veux bien ce serait sympa et on verra on
verra si c'est bien celle qu'on a ici
dans l'article
ainsi c'est parmi les couples les plus
inégalitaires que l'on a pu observer les
plus fortes tensions tu m'étonnes
lorsque le décalage entre la norme
égalitaire et la réalité de la division
du travail est trop grand c'est surtout
le fait que les que tout le monde dans
le couple est intégrée la norme
égalitaire parce que ceux dont on
parlait tout à l'heure avec arnaud
des femmes qui ne veulent pas qu'ils ne
veulent pas que l'homme s'immisce dans
les tâches ménagères elles n'ont
certainement pas intégré la norme
égalitaire or au début on nous a dit que
toutes les personnes qui font partie de
l'échantillon ont conscience de la norme
égalitaire donc voila moi c'est comme ça
que je l'interprète et que je le perçois
les entretiens de ne leur avoir deux
visions antagonistes de la division du
travail domestique et du bonheur
conjugal ainsi qu'une incompréhension
totale entre conjoints trois enquêtes et
éloignées de l'emploi de façon
contrainte assure ainsi l'essentiel des
tâches domestiques cette assignation au
rôle maternel suscite chez elle une
grande souffrance donc voilà il ya une
grande souffrance c'est pas ce que je
viens de dire c'est pas tout les toutes
les femmes qui acceptent la violence
symbolique
[Musique]
non il ya une grande souffrance mais
même on pourrait avoir une acceptation
je pense dans certains cas pas dans le
cas de cette étude mais deux personnes
qui ne sont pas réflexive sur les rôles
inégalitaire mais qui ce qui en
souffriraient quand même dans leur chair
et dans leur mental les couples où la
division du travail est la plus
inégalitaire sont en effet le puits
susceptibles de connaître des disputes
conjugales les tensions les plus fortes
sont le fait de ménages dont la charge
de travail n'est pas allégé par le
recours aux grands-parents donc variable
d'ajustement les grands-parents ou un
signalement ça permet à
la personne dont le couple qui s'occupe
plus des enfants de respirer quelque
part c'est les grands parents qui vont
s'en occuper qui quand ils sont
disponibles constituent une roue de
secours moi je dirais une variable
d'ajustement essentiels comme le disent
plusieurs enquêtés de tous milieux
sociaux ni à des tiers rémunérés parce
que si tu es dans un couple avec des
moyens financiers là tu peux prendre
quelqu'un pour s'occuper de tes gosses
les clous que les couples des classes
supérieures dont certains ont une
organisation très inégalitaire peuvent
eux bénéficié de la guerre domicile ce
que je disais qui à la différence des
crèches et des assistantes maternelles
offre une large amplitude horaire et
permet de la délégation de nombreux
stages comme le repas ou le bain aux
enfants voir le rangement et le ménage
bombay la fille au pair voilà
c'est un peu ça quoi enfin ces
négociations peuvent être conduites avec
prudence par les maires donc le fait de
remettre en cause justement
l'organisation inégalitaire des tâches
ménagères qui minorent leurs attentes
quant à la participation des pères donc
en plus les femmes vont vraiment y aller
mollo par rapport à ça quoi
qu'elles pourraient revendiquer plus une
plus grande égalité puisqu'on est dans
des couples qui ont intégré cette norme
égalitaire et ses nouveaux rôles
parentaux cette modération de leurs
exigences peut s'expliquer par la
perspective de ces pas de la séparation
évoquer explicitement par plusieurs
enquêtés et dont on sait qu'elle expose
les femmes à improviser à la preuve
l'appauvrissement et à la surcharge de
travail domestique nous faisons encore
plus nocta d'état des mecs qui voilà qui
menace c'est carrément ça leur conjointe
de l'équité 6/1 remise en tout cas les
conjointes perçoivent même si c'est pas
dit perçoivent une menace comme celle-là
en cases en cas de remise en question de
l'organisation domestique quoi waouh
alors là on découvre des trucs comme moi
je découvre des trucs
alors qu'on est sûr d'aider des gens qui
qui considère qu' il doit y avoir une
plus grande égalité
pour un individu mariage avec une
personne de rang social inférieur aux
rimes c'est exactement ça donc ta hyper
gamme
c'est ça mais c'est pas exactement ça
quand même j'ai pas aller trop vite
hyper gamme ça va être quand l'homme a
une position sociale ou professionnelle
supérieure et hippo gamme c'est quand sa
position à lui sera inférieure à celle
de saut de sa conjointe les sociétés de
singe fonctionne exactement comme ce que
tu décris ces fascinants on fonctionne
encore comme nos cousins que l'on
considère comme primitif
alors moi j'ai jamais trophée
d'éthologie mais c'est intéressant ce
que tu proposes là sur le chat phoenix
tu as une idée tu as vu cette atteinte à
lui ça t'as vu ça dans un docu
parce que ça m'intéresse ça intéresse
peut-être d'autres dans le tchat
la recherche du moment et des termes
propice pour négocier l'enrôlement des
pères est un travail coûteux en temps en
charge mentale et en contrôle des
émotions pour les mères dans la
passivité des pères peut être forte donc
voilà les femmes elles n'ont pas envie
de s'engager dans ça parce qu'elles
savent que elles vont devoir mettre une
grosse énergie moi j'en mets un petit
peu a décollé que j'avais et qui voulait
changer de boulot mais qui tellement que
le boulot était prenant c'était une
grande distribution tellement qu'on
passait de temps dans le grand dans la
grande surface
voulait changer de boulot mais n'avait
pas l'énergie que de changer parce qu'il
fallait faire des démarches pour trouver
un nouvel emploi et des choses comme ça
quoi pour moi c'est un petit peu la même
chose tu es un peu prisonnier de ce
carcan parce que ça va te demander une
énergie dingue que peut-être que n'a pas
mené avec insistance ce travail menace
au quotidien des branlées l'illusion
conjugale fondée sur la reppe rossi la
réciprocité et la logique du don et de
lui substituer une logique comptable au
risque de briser l'enchantement de la
relation par la mise à nu des rapports
de pouvoir dans le couple
lassé kaufmann qu'en parlant 92 on
entendu on comprend dès lors pourquoi
face aux résistances aux résistance
passive de leur conjoint les maires
peuvent baisser les bras alors ça ce
passage là là moi je suis scotché
vraiment un truc de ouf ce histoire
alors là on est dans la conclusion 1 ça
se termine
je termine à conclusions et puis après
je vais juste ne partez pas tout de
suite je vais vous montrer aussi
tout tout le travail de
comment dire de publications d'aider des
personnes qui ont été interrogées comme
ça vous aurez une bonne vision de
l'observation empirique a été fait mais
notre recherche indique tout autant le
rôle prépondérant des dimensions
matérielle de cette domination les
rapports de pouvoir dans le couple et
l'engagement des pères dont le travail
parentales et domestiques sont largement
déterminée par les inégalités de sexe
et de classe écarts sociaux de revenus
et de conditions d'emploi notamment
contrainte horaire vue évidemment
différents statuts et de richesse entre
conjoints mais aussi configuration
conduisant les pairs à se trouver seul
au foyer
ainsi c'est lorsque les r se trouve
régulièrement à domicile sans leurs
compagnes et où lorsque ces couples sont
hypo gamme que la division du travail
est la moins déséquilibrée dès lors que
leur vision du monde ne vient pas
concurrencer la norme égalitaire oui
parce qu'il pourrait être dans un couple
catholique comme on a vu tout à l'heure
très conservateur avec une l'ordre
naturel ou l'ordre de dieu qui a dit
certaines choses et donc là du coup ça
rentre en
opposition avec cette norme égalitaire
et là je termine avec la dernière phrase
mais je trouve que c'est un peu dommage
parce que dans la conclusion il rappelle
palais les tensions et tout ce dernier
paragraphe flacon à lui qui était assez
scotchant mais alors la dernière phase
monde me parle beaucoup surtout en tant
que lecteur de marx donc aussi conduit
ainsi à rappeler combien l'économie
domestique et liées aux inégalités dans
la sphère productif et aux institutions
régissant la famille puisque on a vu que
l'organisation du travail influence très
profondément et le travail le salarié un
voile a conduit à des situations aussi
et a une influence donc on est dans du
matérialisme aussi voilà je suis plus
sûr vision d'état mais ça m'a vachement
bien parler cette dernière phrase voilà
bonbonnes bibliographie avec bernard
lahire notamment qui cite il faudra en
parler une fois de bernard lahire mais
j'ai envie de le faire bien et donc
c'est pas près d'être fait pas c'est
toujours ça le problème alors je regarde
le plus que vous dites
si j'étais une femme dans cette
situation je partir à l'hôtel à la
charge du salaire de mon mec jusqu'à ce
qu'ils comprennent alors je sais pas ce
que je ferais si j'étais une femme mais
en tout cas où
perso j'aimerais bien qu'on prenne par
exemple soit sur les pingouins ou bien
sûr les aigles la charge mentale est
bien plus égalitaire chez ces êtres
vivants non humains
omeyyades des animaux qui font beaucoup
mieux que nous d'un point de vue social
sur certains points après on fait mieux
que sur d'autres points mais non c'est
sûr c'est sûr
non mais attends mais après je parlais
de marx ici à quelques instants
quand tu vois les abeilles et les
fourmis qui travaille pour la
collectivité pour rien il n'y a pas de
rémunération est rien ils ont fait mieux
que nous conte tout fonctionne long
terme d'organisation sociale ccam le top
maintenant je dis peut-être une bêtise
je connais je comprends pas je connais
pas je suis pas être au look non plus
reportage art est super intéressant sur
les différentes sociétés animales
fourmis phoque etc il ya longtemps
phoenix
ce que je crois qu'il ya moyen de le
retrouver
c'est vrai que les oiseaux nous donne
souvent de beaux exemples tout à fait
d'accord surtout dans les rapports de
pouvoir notamment dans les couples c'est
même fascinant je passe ma vie à les
observer et à les nourrir
mais je sais pas si tu étais là quand
j'en avais déjà parlé arnaud bonnard
mais voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils si moi
aussi je suis passionné c'est les
libellules et la botanique qui me
passionne beaucoup
mais voilà c'est passionnant c'est
passionnant les comportements animaux
c'est passionnant cible
mais les hommes étant des animaux
c'est aussi intéressant de les observer
il ya aussi les sociétés matriarcales
asiatiques et africaines qui sont très
intéressante dans leur fonctionnement
oui mais voilà l'exemple donc je prends
tout le temps c'est la société d'émotion
je montre ça aux élèves parce qu'il ya
plein de reportages qui ont été faits
la chaîne foule aux copies vient de
sortir un truc sur l'autogestion des
full
full aux copies c'est une chaîne youtube
où c'est une chaîne twitch
un peu on le retrouvera peut-être pas
mais bon voilà vous avez vous êtes dans
le discorde si vous voyez le moindre
truc intéressant comme ça n'hésitez pas
à vous le taper dans le bis corde ça
coûte rien moi je regarderai si ça peut
être l'objet d'un stream
et ont construit les choses ensemble moi
je veux pas que
ce qui m'intéresse dans le cleach c'est
un rapport bon même si c'est moi qui aie
qu'elle est reine du truc et qui parlait
tout ça mais voilà c'est un truc qu'on
construit ensemble moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse sur twitter par rapport à
youtube youtube je suis tout seul dans
mon bureau a travaillé sur les vidéos
quand tu fais un truc sur twitch ça
prend tout de suite une autre dimension
ça devient un truc sociale tu vois on va
beaucoup plus
social c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
où l'os copie mais me semble que j'ai
déjà entendu parler de cette chaîne
c'est c'est pas vous qui aviez parlé sur
le
la foule peut être organisée sans chef
et d'ailleurs tu vois les bancs de
sardines tout va qui bougent qu'ils font
ces mouvements incroyable les murmures
des étourneaux tout ça est organisée
sans chef parce que chez les fourmis
chez la reine qui a faim chez les
abeilles tu pourrais dire il ya une
reine mais voilà le les bancs de
sardines voilà qui voyagent ensemble et
ça c'est sans chef ou les oies ou des
choses comme ça c'est c'est formidable
ça fonctionne sans chef
je regarderai alors je vous mets le lien
je sais pas ce que ça vaut pas ce que
moi j'ai jamais regardé c'est
une recommandation
[Musique]
d'arnaud je vous le mets ici voilà
pour être des thèmes aussi intéressant
vous savez quoi je vais taper ça dans le
dans le
discorde
on va mettre dans discorde ce qu'on
pourrait rechercher
jeu mais quelques thèmes
travaillés sur la charge mentale bon on
va être un peu plus dans le
psychologique mais pourquoi pas on fait
ce qu'on veut
charge mentale éthologie
quoi d'autre j'avais dit un truc aussi
que pouvait être intéressant
je sais plus quoi
dit tellement de choses
et théologie
je ne sais plus il ya un truc j'ai dit
pendant le stream
ou y'a pas de soucis ou alors sur
youtube sûr
je pars sur vous pouvez envoyer sur dur
comme on dira me taguées dans twitter la
société ecc ça ça peut être intéressant
j'aime assista - tu
tu réponds annonce est à phoenix
voilà donc article je pense assez
intéressant où il ya des choses qu'on
apprend mais pas comme en sciences
sociales j'ai envie de dire vraiment des
des choses de fond donc ça c'était sympa
je vais juste vous montrer ici tout le
travail empirique qui a été fait
j'ai remonté un peu la fenêtre parce que
là c'est un peu n'importe quoi
voilà donc ici vous voyez il ya vraiment
tous les enquêtés qui sont
qui sont précisées alors on aurait
peut-être aimé avoir aussi quelques
éléments
de vécu moi j'aurais vraiment rajouter
une colonne devant un petit peu ce
qu'ils racontaient quoi
et donc là il ya vraiment un travail de
codification on peut tout retracer
donc ça c'est sympa
comme annexe et la bibliographie qui
étaient ici
allez les pères les conditions de
l'engagement des hommes dans le travail
domestiques et parentales voilà c'était
très intéressant
comme article finalement j'étais un peu
déçu que l'article de thibaut b2dix ne
soit pas sélectionné mais c'est une
bonne surprise aussi
eh bien on a bien mais encore une fois
on a fait quoi deux heures de stream
c'était sympathique
avec vous
j'essaie de retrouver ma fenêtre mais je
trouve que ma fenêtre où est elle non
c'est pas celle là voilà la voici
merci merci
alors désolé phoenix et léa de vous
interrompre dans votre discussion
vous la continuerai
j'en suis convaincu une prochaine fois
alors on se donne pas rendez vous
mercredi ou jeudi aura pas de stream je
rappelle pas de stream mercredi jeudi ni
dimanche c'est la fête ici à ercis et on
se retrouve donc mercredi dans une
semaine et demie pour une petite lecture
classique alors je sais pas encore ce
qu'on verra on verra à ce moment-là on a
bien le temps d'ici là voilà merci
encore de votre soutien votre
participation d'avoir fait vivre ce chat
c'était beau merci allait l'inculper
mais aussi à panda rouge merci à don
quichotte
merci à phoenix merci à arnaud nanar
merci à prof le nain merci à luis bottes
un merci quand même à lui même si ces
personnes
merci il y avait encore eu d'autres
personnes je pense sur le tchat merci à
à mitte qui est passé ça fait plaisir ça
me tue qui est vraiment le quitter le
50e follower de la chaîne merci à mr mme
houde qui est passé aussi n'hésitez pas
à paulo et si vous regardez en replay ça
permet de créer un petit lien entre nous
et ces sympathiques je vous dis merci et
à très bientôt salut salut
[Musique]